hey youtubers is charlie totally
unexpected they're dropping the rogue
one teaser tomorrow morning they
revealed a new storm trooper so let's
proceed to freak out in an orderly
fashion just because this is such an
unexpected really awesome surprise i'm
going to do a special giveaway for Star
Wars stuff we'll go ahead and say force
awakens DVD all you have to do to enter
the giveaway is be a subscriber and
leave a comment on this video whenever I
post the big teaser trailer video
tomorrow I'll announce who the winner is
but if you have no idea what's going on
with rogue one it's one of the Star Wars
anthology film it's going to tell the
story of how the rebels stole the plans
for the very first Death Star so the
idea is is it by the end of that film we
might be picking up with the initial
events of episode 4 they're allowing the
anthology films to jump around in the
timeline so they're not all going to be
set during the time of force awakens but
another really good example of that is
the han solo film that they're working
on right now it's going to tell his
origin story they've been looking for a
young version of han Solo they haven't
officially revealed to all the rogue one
characters are but we know that mass
mickelson is playing one of the Empire
characters which is funny because I just
talked about him being in the Doctor
Strange movie as a big villain but I'm
most excited for Felicity Jones
character in donnie yen the rumor is is
that Donnie Yen is going to be a blind
Jedi if you haven't been watching Star
Wars rebels they've been playing around
with the idea of what happened to the
Jedi after the purge they are still
force users out there so it's totally
possible that Donnie Yen could be a
blind force user but we can talk more
about those characters when they drop
the actual teaser so be sure to
subscribe to get that video tonight is
going to be big arrow WTF really awesome
Star Wars footage coming tomorrow
morning in that movie is dropping in
December if you guys didn't know that
the next week first Doctor Strange
trailer and more captain america civil
war so Marvel and Disney are doubling
down remember Star Wars is also owned by
disney so of course they're going to use
captain america civil war to promote the
other Marvel films as well as the Star
Wars films while you guys wait for my
next video to post if you haven't seen
them you can click here for my star wars
the force awakens easter eggs and you
can click here for my captain america
civil war behind-the-scenes video thank
you so much watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight me
me me me
you